what's going on guys this is Rob if you
guys enjoy my content make sure you hit
the subscribe button and make sure you
hit that little bell so you never miss
out on my sexy voice
what's going on guys this is Rob and I
wanted to make a video explaining the
character of cable something first
though somebody asked me the question
they were like why don't you script your
your videos when you do these honestly
because for me it's just as much of a
challenge to see if I can remember to do
this all off the top of my head as it is
fun to do these things off the top of my
head so I kind of like the idea of not
really being scripted to me like doing
things scripted kind of makes them
boring to me I like the challenge of
seeing if I could really recall all this
reading all this comic book knowledge
off the top of my head but again I want
to talk about cable here so when Marvel
Comics Cable has a couple different
origins there is the original origin for
the character of Nathan and then there
is the modified origin that Marvel
offered back in cable issue number six
and even actually a couple of issues or
a couple stories that came after that
one of which was the adventures of
Cyclops in Phoenix in 1994 1987 and so
going all the way back really kind of
kind of taking an in adventure through
time and going all the way back to the
Stanley Jack Kirby days of Marvel Comics
by and large gene was one of the weakest
characters who was there she was always
being rescued she was really really
incapable and the result was that she
didn't really seem to serve a purpose
and so when the x-men line of comics was
kind of canceled and then relaunched
with giant-size x-men issue number one
going into issue number 94 which was
basically written by Chris Claremont and
his goal over the course of well really
from the issues in the 90s right I guess
that you know 1994 running all the way
up until I want to say that the 130s or
one 40s it was basically the Phoenix and
the Dark Phoenix saga and the reason why
this matters and the reason why it's
important for the character of cable is
because what it did is it basically
revolutionized the character of Jean and
fans loved her but the idea of Claremont
was to always killed you that was the
whole point was to really really build
her up make her huge make her wildly
popular and then have her go out with a
bang which he did the result of this was
that Claremont's the next step was to
basically bring in a character named
Madeline Pryor and what you ended up
learning was that somewhere along the
line the villain sinister a mr. sinister
in Nathaniel Essex had become obsessed
with the idea that if Jean Grey and
Cyclops ever had a son or ever had any
kind of a child their child would be
insanely Papa and sanely powerful and
the goal of sinister was to initiate a
coupling between the two and then take
the child and raise it as his own
way he could basically defeat the
villain sinister I'm sorry defeat the
villain apocalypse which made mr.
sinister into who he was and then also
use it to achieve his own goals and
defeat the x-men and so on and so forth
and so the result of this is that the
Madeline Pryor clone of Jean Grey was
sent forward into the world after Jean
had died and then discovered Cyclops and
Cyclops who had abandoned the x-men
after the death of Jean saw Madeline
prior and while he knew it wasn't really
Jean ultimately he ended up just kind of
getting with her and the two of them had
a child now this coincided with the
launch of what Marvel called the
x-factor comics this was basically the
original Stanley a Stan Lee and Jack
Kirby x-men being reformed under a
different name and so what ended up
happening is because Jean was so
incredibly popular from the Marvel
Comics fan base Marvel brought her back
but the idea was that she had to be
exonerated for the crimes she committed
during the Phoenix in Dark Phoenix saga
when she had like destroyed a star and
killed billions of people on a on a
planet so what Marvel did is they sort
of came up with this ad hoc explanation
and what they said was that the Jean
Grey as the Phoenix
wasn't actually Jean instead that
version of Jean was recovering in the
bottom of Jamaica Bay and the Phoenix
had impersonated her so the x-men found
the real Jean Grey
she returned Cyclops abandoned Madeline
prior and went back to the original Jean
and they formed the x-factor team but
the reason why this is important is
because during the time when Cyclops and
Madeline were together they had a son
and the son was named Nathan now the way
this whole thing worked out was that you
had the villain apocalypse who realized
what it was a sinister wanted to do and
so apocalypse in as his forces to
capture Nathan and then bring him to the
blue area of the Moon which is a portion
of the Moon where you can basically
breathe oxygen and so the x-men and the
Inhumans and xfactor responded and in
the middle of the fight we ended up
finding out that apocalypse had infected
this little baby with something called
the techno-organic virus and what does
duh what this did is it basically
started converting the baby's physical
flesh into machinery more or less and
the idea was that if the baby could
survive it then it was worthy of being a
host for apocalypse if the baby couldn't
survive it then it wasn't worthy and so
because of the fact that the baby was
infected apocalypse was fought off by
x-factor x-men in the Inhumans a woman
just appeared out of nowhere in the
future and simply said give the baby to
me I'll
into the future we'll try to find a cure
and the baby was handed over and that
was the end of that it was supposed to
be written out it was supposed to be
gone forever that was the whole point
the idea behind this though was that
around that time I would say probably
going all the way back to the early
1980s Marvel had launched new mutants
and new mutants was basically designed
to be a replacement for the x-men team
with Charles Xavier believing they had
died and the new mutants were hugely
popular at the time and so what we ended
up doing was he basically picked up with
the launch of the new mutants title but
as time progressed you had Chris
Claremont who wrote it for about the
first 49 issues or so I think and then
you had Louise Simonson who took over
between issues 50 to 85 roughly she was
editor for it towards the end of her run
and then you had Rob Liefeld who came on
his writer and then he picked up with
issue number 86 and so what Rob Liefeld
did is he introduced the character of
cable and initially we didn't know
anything about it
we had no idea who cable was we just
knew he was this guy who was pretty
intense in terms of how he was depicted
and then he basically took over the the
New Mutants team and so wounded up
happening is between issues number 86 of
New Mutants running up to issue number
100 and then picking up with the
continuation as far as x-force number
one it was a seamless transition New
Mutants was cancelled with 100 and it
continued on with x-force number one and
Liefeld had basically groomed the team
in such a way to where they were
basically a strike force for cable
that's really what they were now once
you got into the x-force line of comics
a whole host of things basically sort of
being explained the issue with this is
that rifle Rob Liefeld left after about
the first ten issues due to a lot of
issues and he was headed with Marvel
Comics he took off with guys like Jim
Lee and a handful of other people in
order to launch Image Comics and so
following issue number 10 you ended up
having Fabien Aziza who took over and
then you know continued riding it going
on until you know however long and so
during this whole time a lot of
backstory was given about the character
of cable but not really towards his
origin instead under Rob Liefeld and
Fabien Aziza what we ended up learning
is that cable was from the future and
we're the the latter story of New
Mutants and the basically initial
offerings of Rob Liefeld in x-force
dealt with the villains strife we really
didn't know a whole lot about him but we
did know that cable and strife had
basically been battling all throughout
time that they both came from the future
they've been following each other
they've been chasing around and
different things like that and engaging
any different skirmishes and so
following that we basically found out
that during this x-force series that
cable had basically arrived before he
was first depicted in the New Mutants
line of comics and what he had was a
group called six-pack which consisted of
people like GW bridge and Kane and so on
and so forth
he actually abandoned them and basically
allowed him to die more or less because
of a whole campaign that was screwed up
but they basically worked for a guy
named mr. Tolliver and mr. Tolliver was
really really ambiguous but what he
ended up learning in New Mutants issue
number 98 coincidentally the first
appearance of Deadpool is that mr.
Toliver is actually the son of cable
from the future who travelled back in
time and had a vendetta against his
father and tried to take him out and so
going forward really from x-force
running all the way up until the time
that it was canceled really going even
even so far is until like the mid-2000s
or really the early 2000s what you had
was you had the x-force line of comics
and then you had the cable line of
comics because cable was hugely popular
under Rob Liefeld I mean he was massive
he was everything about the 1990s as so
many fans a lot
he was intense the x-force team faced
off against Strife's Mutant Liberation
Front there were all kinds of these
different odd different schemes that
were going on and you would even have
stories where x-force would face off
against x-factor or even the x-men and
so one of the big things to really come
out of this one of the big explosive
concepts to come out of the car come out
of the involvement of cable in the
mid-1990s and even x-force itself was a
story called executioner song an
executioner's song again really focus on
the character of strife but it was the
furthering of this Vendetta and and
really they kind of established that the
various appearances the strife had had
over the course of Marvel Comics were
just small little battles that were part
of a much larger war and so the idea of
executioner song was basically strife
and personating table and then trying to
eliminate Professor Charles Xavier
ultimately the x-men x-force and an
x-factor
learned what was going on they teamed up
they faced off against strife and in the
middle of the battle you basically had
cable who was kind of thrown into the
timestream
and it was believed that he was killed
alongside strife now what that did is it
allowed for Marvel to remove cable from
the landscape temporarily and that's why
if you go through and you look at
x-force cables in there for about the
first 18 issues and then he's gone for
seven
and returns with issue number 25 because
it was a way to sort of remove him gauge
the direction that x-force was going in
and see what was going on the other half
of this is that by the time issue number
18 had hit we were on our way to the
mid-1990s comic bust and so with the
character of cable and with the whole
title of x-force it was kind of a
reshuffling now going on from from
really like the the return of cable and
the x-force comics and going into the
future of marvel I would even say
running up as far as 2004 for the most
part he was kind of free-floating he was
there and he had some cool stories but
he wasn't nearly as prominent as he had
been during like the major force of his
time on x-force by Fabian aziza and Rob
Liefeld because for the most part going
into the mid 1990s comic busts and
coming into the aftermath of it which is
to say the late 1990s going into the
early 2000s what you had was Marvel
trying to find ways to make titles work
and it wasn't really a situation where
they could gamble on titles that weren't
guaranteed to be successful and so
that's why you ended up seeing things
like the Marvel Knights imprint where
you basically had characters like
daredevil and and a handful of others
who weren't guaranteed to sell that were
published by a really kind of kind of
handled by Joe Quesada and Jimmy palmy
oddities event publications and then
print I guess saw published by Marvel
comments itself and so going into that
whole that whole situation cabled has
kind of floated around he was there he
had some involvement stories like the
The Adventures of Cyclops and Phoenix
help to flush out his origin basically
saying that the the in term gap between
him as a baby being sent to the future
and when he first appeared followed the
format that when he arrived in the
future that he was basically cloned and
the whole idea behind this was that
there was no guarantee that Nathan being
infected with a techno-organic virus
would be what would basically allow him
to survive and so the clone was created
in case Nathan died the issue with this
was that the villain apocalypse had
basically ruled the world four thousand
million for four thousand years in the
future and so in response to this when
apocalypse realized that Nathan was in
the present day he sent his forces to
essentially gather him up and they ended
up taking the clone instead of the
actual cable and so the minds of Jean
Grey and Cyclops were transported to the
future they raised cable they taught him
how to use his powers and apocalypse
raised the clone and so the clone ended
up becoming strife and the character of
cable ended up becoming the
of cable with regards to a solo series
in the 1990s there were a lot of people
who took part in it but with regards to
a solo series in the 1990s where you at
cable vol 1 you had sold your ex you had
things like a Scotty son the the the
series that feature him what ended up
happening is a lot of this focused on
the war between cable and stripe that
you had the the new Canaanites you had
the Clan chosen you had cables forces
versus stripes forces that you kind of
had this ongoing battle between the two
even after Apocalypse had been defeated
and that's one of the reasons why strife
had jumped back in time cable would
follow him cable would go back further
strife would follow him they would just
kind of take potshots and it was very
much a kind of tie manipulating guerilla
war a guerrilla war that was going on
between the two and so again going into
the early 2000s cable was a character
who was really reminiscent of a bygone
era and Marvel and the reason why I say
this is because in the early 2000s
around 2001 running up to 2004 you had a
kind of branding initiative called x-men
reload and what this was designed to do
is it was really spearheaded by the
departure of Grant Morrison accident
being taken up by Chuck Austin and then
the direction of Joe Quesada which
basically said we work the entirety of
the x-men that the x-men are basically
rooted in 1990s they haven't really
moved forward since Chris Claremont
originally left and you had guys like we
had guys like like Jim Lee who took up
the pin the whole idea was reinvigorate
them reinitiate them and so some of the
titles were canceled some of them were
renamed and the focus was on the
original x-men teams following this and
going into 2004 the entire x-men
population was reduced in scale now
there were some other things that went
on here for example because cable was
considered to be an ailing character and
despite the fact that that writers like
like like Gail Simone writers like
Christopher priests had tried to work on
the character of Deadpool and beefed him
up ultimately they weren't the highest
selling publications Marvel hat and so
their response was why not copy what
they did in the 1970s with Iron Fist and
Luke Cage and just pair these characters
together and so what we got is we got
cable and Deadpool vol 1 and it was
actually hugely popular it was massively
popular and it dealt with a lot of
different themes when you had Fabian
decieves or riding cable and Deadpool
vol 1 the whole notion was to take cable
or I'm sorry take Deadpool and his
nonsensical elements which had basically
been initially established
Joe Kelly and built on and expanded on
by Christopher priest and put those
side-by-side with with cable himself and
cable had always been like a super
serious hardcore mercenary and where
they were initially enemies you know in
New Mutants initially number 98 and were
enemies even following that with
Deadpool's various appearances in the
x-force comics them coming together and
working as a unified team was
beautifully done because you would
basically see Deadpool annoy cable more
than anything else and cable would just
get pissed off at him all the time but
they would still work together but for
the cable and Deadpool line of comics
running forward 450 issues until it was
cancelled
they got appearance as a lot of
different stories basically what you had
is you had them sort of covering the
background with regards to the fact that
cable was the reason Apocalypse rose to
power in the first place you had things
like them hobby you know humming back
and forth through time you had a lot of
escapades things like civil war for
example when Marvel Civil War event
kicked off you had a cable who showed up
to the office of the president and said
look you cannot do this it's gonna cause
all kinds of problems later on down the
line but again because of the fact that
it blended humor with a serious tone it
was hugely successful or at least it was
at the time and so with issue number 58
was canceled a cable was somewhat
free-floating again what we ended up
having was the cable series which was
broken off or at least from cable and
Deadpool they were both broken off cable
got a second volume of a series Deadpool
got another volume of his series and
cables volume of course was canceled and
that led into his return with Messiah
Complex now going into Messiah Complex
this was kind of a culmination really of
like eight years of reworking the x-men
in the sense that after the events of
house of M when the Scarlet Witch had
stripped 98% of the meetin population of
their powers you only had 198 mutants
left and so focusing on that 198 and
even then focusing even more on the core
x-men it was a chance for Marvel to
begin going through and start bringing
back elements that have been
historically popular and then create new
elements that would go on to be popular
as well and so what you ended up having
was the character of Hope Summers who
was born in Anchorage Alaska and
initially when the x-men when the
purifiers basically this religious
fundamentalist group who thinks that God
wants them to kill mutants when you had
the Marauders of mr. sinister
who all showed up in in Alaska trying to
get this kid Hope Summers that it was
basically gone at least at the time the
baby was unnamed what we call it hope
because that's what we ended up you know
what the baby ended up being named but
the baby had vanished and what you ended
up finding out is that Professor Xavier
had actually contacted cable
telepathically and said you have to go
get this baby it's the last hope for
like the rise of humanity and ultimately
because Cyclops is getting more and more
extreme with regards to how he deals
with various threats that are out there
he'd be just inclined to kill the baby
as he would be to actually save it and
so K boy basically whisked into Alaska
he bought it he basically body slid into
Alaska took the baby body slid out and
then was on the run and so what you
ended up having was a sort of
time-traveling caper in the newest
iteration of the cable series really
about Craig Kyle and Chris Yost which
dealt with him jumping back and forward
through time and the entire basis behind
this was to take the baby to keep it
safe from a threat that wasn't
immediately identified now over the
course of Messiah Complex going into
Messiah War what you basically had was
us learning that the the person who was
who had been tracking down cable and
host summers was actually the character
of Bishop and Bishop was very much a
superhero who was part of the x-men for
quite some time but his past was very
ambiguous we knew he came from a history
that was much like Days of Future past
he came from a future there was much
like Days of Future past but unlike the
Days of Future past where they when the
signals had just conquered everything
and that was the end of that what you
had was an event called the Sommers
rebellion and the Sommers rebellion
basically was a coming together of
humans and mutants to cast off the
central threat after that there was
still kind of a tenuous relationship but
mutants were allowed to police
themselves by way of something called
the Xavier security enforcers and so
where Bishop had come from that future
we didn't really know what caused it we
largely assumed it was an assassination
or something along those lines but what
Messiah Complex of Messiah War did is it
consolidated all those themes down and
said at some point along the line Hope
Summers is going to initiate something
called the six-second war and what's
gonna happen in this war and she's going
to annihilate 1 million humans in 6
seconds and when that happens it's going
to jumpstart basically Days of Future
past and it's gonna lead to future star
leave the bishops timeline and so
bishops idea was kill host summers and
that was the whole point
it was jumping back and forth it was
basically cable and Hope jumping forward
into the future jumping back into the
and Bishop chasing after them by homing
on to their signatures in the timestream
now following this and it was actually a
point where cable was believed to have
been dead
he basically seemed to sacrifice his
life and that really came out of uncanny
x-force at least I believe it was
uncanny or maybe was just x-force vol 3
vol 2 or vol 3 I can never remember
which one and the whole idea here was
that as you know because cable had taken
the baby and jumped into the future
Cyclops had responded by reforming
x-force with Wolverine at the helm and
so because x-force as it was reformed by
Wolverine was again a kind of blackops
Strikeforce team their job was to find
cable and so what ended up happening is
they jumped all the way and you know
managed to really track him down that
goes into the battle between like cable
the returns strife apocalypse the x-men
I guess x-force that kind of a thing and
a cable basically opens a portal to
allow them to bring Hope Summers back to
the modern day but dies in the process
when his whole you know techno-organic
virus runs over him just because of the
fact that for cable he has to use his
telepathy and telekinesis to keep the
virus at bay and so because of this when
the virus overrides his body he
basically ends up dying and cables
written now now cable eventually comes
back and this was really part of a
pretty significant event that was called
I believe it was called a vengers ex
sanction I'm pretty sure that's funny
return and the whole basis behind this
was that you essentially had like second
coming and you you had hoped Summers who
was travelling around the world and
basically waking up the powers of
various mutants and it was away from
Marvell to kind of give her her own team
was called generation Hope but it was
away from Marvell to give her her own
team and sort of shuffle the pieces
around and kind of launch a more modern
version of the new mutants and so with
that in mind what we ended up having was
cable traveling back to the modern day
after realizing or at least gaining
information that's somewhere along the
line The Avengers are gonna kill Hope
Summers and so when he jumps back to the
modern day he basically goes through and
like starts crushing the Avengers I mean
literally takes them on and just starts
wrecking them quite readily now
ultimately it leads to him basically
contacting the x-men meeting back up
with Hope Summers and Hope Summers hears
him of tourism of the techni organic
virus and that was something that was
John Donne just because of the fact that
though techno-organic virus for cable
had just kind of been this this bygone
element that didn't really seem to
matter anymore because it was just it
was a situation that was really more of
hindrance than a help when it came to
like the progression of his character
and so what ended up happening here is
you had cable who had fallen into a coma
after he was healed and then he was
basically gone but during that coma I
guess he ended up returning but during
that point when he was in a coma he
spoke directly with Cyclops and this is
one of the things that kicks off
Avengers vs. x-men because while he's
talking with Cyclops what he basically
says is from the future that cable comes
from Hope Summers becomes wildly
important she basically leads like you
know has the potential to lead like a
new kind of utopian era of mutants and
so Cyclops has to do whatever it takes
in order to keep her safe and that's the
reason why when you read Avengers vs.
x-men the whole conflict kicks off
because Cyclops is operating under
information given to him by cable that
Hope Summers has to be kept safe under
any possible circumstance now from here
going forward into really like the the I
would say probably going into like the
the Secret Wars landscape because Marvel
was really kind of winding down from
Avengers vs. x-men well you didn't have
cable who appeared a couple more times
like in the Deadpool miniseries split
second well you had like that those
situations that kind of transpired for
him by and large people began to take
somewhat of a backseat again and it
wasn't really until the second volume of
uncanny Avengers that he popped back up
and the reason why was because following
the events of Avengers vs. x-men because
the conflict had been so intense and
because the possibility existed that
either the Avengers could have wiped out
the x-men or the x-men could have wiped
out the Avengers that Captain America
kind of split the difference and said
well let's create an Avengers unity
squad and so what this will do is it'll
take x-men and it'll take Avengers and
it'll put them on a singular team hence
the name uncanny Avengers it borrows the
uncanny x-men combined with the Avengers
title puts them together and thus we
have that team and so for the year the
first volume of uncanny Avengers didn't
really feature cable at all the second
volume did and that really kicked off an
all-new all-different marvel which was a
cable led team and much like the the the
kind of situation we expected when it
when it came with him he was basically
leading under the idea that like the
future was dire and you know summerlee's
he was part of it the future was die on
terrible things were gonna happen and
and so on and so forth but again that's
this kind of work cable resides at the
moment to be honest I'm not a hundred
percent sure what's going on with him in
the here and now honestly I'm not that
caught up with Marvel yet so I guess you
know maybe I should have researched that
portion
before this video but with everything
that we've explained I think we've done
a pretty good job but that's kind of the
funny thing is I'll probably end up
doing a video actually I think that
we've done a video about the powers of
Cable in terms of what he's capable of
um that that's kind of the crazy thing
because even when you look back at
events like house of him one of the ways
that Marvel kind of reworked the
character of cable is that in the
Deadpool and cable miniseries are I
guess the Deadpool in Cable ongoing
series because it coincided with the
events of house of them you actually had
cable swept up just like everybody else
when the Scarlet Witch worked reality
and when dead or when Deadpool found
cable he had actually been D aged and
turned into a baby and so when they
jumped out of the time stream and
avoided the skull at which basically
saying no more mutants and setting
everything back cable-stayed a baby and
it was away from Marvel to kind of age
him up but put him at a teenager and try
to make him like the new x-man Nate gray
didn't really work people didn't really
like it too much it was it was okay for
what it was but it wasn't that great but
there's been times where his powers have
been it like their full force there's
been times where his powers have been
weaker than they ever were before he's
really kind of bounced around over the
years I would say by and large cables
heyday was a 99 he's really the early
1990s after that it was really hard to
make its character work because the
stories weren't really about like super
high-octane action anymore it wasn't
about like dark stories where everything
runs a mile a minute and it's all super
super intense that was really cables
whole element going into like the early
2000s things were a little slower
they were darker in a lot of ways but
things were also a little slower too
because it was about tearing down Marvel
as it existed before the 2000s and
building it back up again to really fit
in in kind of cater to a new generation
of readers and so again hopefully this
guy is helped you guys figure out the
character of cable hopefully you have a
better understanding about him if you
are new here too comments explained make
sure you guys hit the sub button to
become part of the Rob core if you guys
enjoyed this video make sure you drop a
like and yeah I will catch you all later
peace
[Music]